[Music]
alright guys so we're on Hatteras Island
and we're gonna be meeting David Wilson
to go do a shelling and clamming charter
here now we're pretty excited hi Simon
how you do it alright welcome aboard Tom
welcome aboard need alright guys so
we're pushing off we're gonna go do a
3-hour clamming and shelling charter
here with godspeed charters David
Wilson's gonna hook us up here and I'm
gonna put leaks in the description
Tommy this might be a secret pirate
island oh that's that's a no that's an
out of shell and you will find these and
all colors and size
my god well that's a huge clamp clamps
well that's huge
[Music]
goodness show me your coins hold on your
hand oh my goodness oh yeah we got some
good stuff here these pirates are
international travelers Wow look at what
you found you've got so many big ones oh
yeah
now the captain said they're over by
that tree it was a good spot to look for
seashells so I go yeah this is just an
awesome awesome thing to do that our own
little island here the kids get a play
we're having a great time there's a nice
piece of anthracite it looks like it
looks like a fighting Oh
[Music]
you know one really nice thing about
this is there's really nothing to hurt
the kids on this island the water is not
deep there's no big waves no strangers
no wild animals poison snakes you can
just kind of do whatever they want and I
can see him anywhere on this island
[Music]
[Music]
you guys ready to go get some clams
let's go get some clams
just kind of walk as we drag it all
right so clam dig it's pretty simple
we've got these rakes now have these big
tines on them and you just drag it
through the mud and you'll feel this LT
when you hit something that feels like a
rock then you go back and you scrape it
up and pop out comes the clam as long as
it's more than one inch across you can
keep them in the limits a hundred a day
per person so we're gonna gonna limit
out today there's one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you feel that oh look we've found
it's a whelk
that is so cool look put it in the
basket
[Music]
well Becca's in the boat watching Jacob
but this is too much fun I think I
better give her a big one baby now you
kind of hit the same spat aren't you
Jacob never eat before I but I know you
can't eat them so let's uh let's take it
home see we chose Bop
believe that guys that is a pile of
clams
if the clams are gonna escape now's our
chance to make a break for it do you
guys have a good time doing that no
would you like do it again awesome all
right we made it back to the beach house
and the bucket full of clams tipped over
when I hit the brakes and so we have
clams all over the back of the car what
I've got here is I've got a big bucket
of fresh water here and I'm just putting
the clams in kind of rinsing off and to
kind of try to keep them a little bit
cool okay I've got the clams rinsed off
and they've been sitting in the fresh
water for a little while and they've
purged out a lot of their sand we're
gonna go ahead and make some deep fried
pull boy clam sandwiches here so let me
show you how it's done we're gonna set
aside the whelk and then the clams I'm
gonna put in this pot over here add
enough water to completely submerge the
clams and put them on a medium to high
heat and boil them for about three
minutes they should pop open quite
suddenly as soon as you get it boiling
and then just drain off all the water
and you'll see that some of the clam
meat has separated on its own from the
shells and just pick that up and set it
aside
other times you just take a little bit
of a knife and you just there's one
little tendon there you just slice it
and it pops right out it's really easy
there's a tendon on the bottom of the
shell and the top of the shell and
whichever one's sticking just kind of
hit it with the knife doesn't take much
and it separates if the clam is still
closed just get in there and pry it over
with a knife it's not too hard and then
just separate both the top and bottom
pendants here you're done even Nathan
helped out then you go rinse off the
meat to make sure you get rid of all the
sand and grit and then you can go ahead
and just eat them as is smaller clams
that's exactly if you do but these are
bigger clams and so there's
you still inside it so kind of find a
little green ball underneath the skin of
the meat and just slice it kind of cut
the meat and a half long wise and just
kind of butterfly it open and you'll see
kind of the green stuff that you don't
want to eat and just run underwater and
come right out so you can go ahead and
just gonna butterfly all the clams we
get and get all that stuff out
then take the bowl of clam meat and
season it with Old Bay seasoning as much
or as little as you like and then take
the meat and roll it in all-purpose
flour you can even add a little bit of
the seasoning to the flour if you like
then put it in some beaten egg just
cover it nicely in the egg get all the
excess off and then put it in some
seasoned panko breadcrumbs take a little
glob of breadcrumbs and eggs and test
out your oil the oil should be pretty
hot and it should brown up nice and
quick so you can just kind of flash fry
good plants if you overdo them they get
kind of rubbery but there you go
perfectly golden brown then this is
clams
then for the buns of the po-boy
sandwiches take some French bread loaves
kind of long wise rubbed with a little
olive oil the salt or the garlic powder
a little bit of basil and then just put
them in the oven and broil them the high
temperature keep a close eye on it then
slice up some tomatoes and salt them and
you're ready to go just make sure you
watch that bread because it'll Brown
very quickly there you goes got some
garlic bread we take a bunch of these
tram nuggets tartar sauce there you go
that is fried clam po boy right there
good I like it
you like it mm-hmm it's partnered seven
it's so fun
well this is fun I had such a good time
babe didn't you I had a great time and
you did a good job cooking I don't love
seafood but you did a good job thank you
babe thank you
well guys we absolutely love that clam
po-boy it was delicious unfortunately I
cannot say the same thing for the whelk
I looked up online how to cook well and
it was recommended to remove the meat
from the shell that you boil it for
about five minutes and then you could
just take a fork and pop it out this
turned out not to be the case it just
would not come out and I bet several
Forks I tried to get in there as far as
it could see if I cut cut loose some
tendons in the end we only got some of
the meat out what meat I did get out of
the shell was so rubbery it was
virtually an out edible it was like
chewing the rubber hose so I'm gonna
learn more about that maybe in the
future I could I could figure out how to
cook well well guys I hope you enjoyed
this video if you want to see more great
videos from the outdoor boys YouTube
channel don't forget to click Subscribe
we put out new videos every Saturday
morning and we have a number of really
awesome Captain Cook videos to check out
thanks for watching have a great day if
you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button so you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
let's show me what you're eating what do
they taste like Giggy but are they
delicious